thomas numero 4 sto portando culto fare
le sue cose oggi giorno speciale
affitteremo la casa trasformeremo
completamente da casa spoglia reda
diventerà regia del natale avevamo due
alberi di due metri e mezzo che un'idea
assurda per farlo e poi un botto delusi
potremmo illuminare una città tutte le
mettere all'interno dell'abitazione
rischiare di prendere fuoco è bello e
culto non sei contento come sei eccoti
ora con la scusa di dover portare punto
per i suoi bisogni sto andando a
comprare nelle ultime cose che mi
servono per creare questa struttura lo
parlano di una struttura architettonica
che servirà per fare da puntale
all'albero che stava facendo intanto a
casa
remo stremo bassa michela kabanga noi
output gli occhi di aqaba tornati solo
sette case in e spengono il piccante gli
sto cercando di creare un mix di fiocchi
dh banda dc come troppo falloso alla
banda secondo me c'è qualcosa di strano
non vedo l'ora di tornare a casa ragazzi
stavano dormendo quindi teoricamente li
dovrei trovare ancora letto macigno
innanzitutto ti serve questo è ovvio che
le suore del gatto viner mood urbano
brulla lo faranno risveglierò nelle luci
di natale per rendere questa giornata
una giornata calma
serena è all'insegna della pace del
natale trovato il boom
no no no no no stiamo cominciando cerchi
dell'upa ti faccio vedere io che cosa la
faccio conducente faccio credere che
siamo amici
un cerchietto bellissimo pensa cosa
farebbe
ma se io scrivere solo libero ok
occupato vendiamo davanti al cesso ma
prima ho anche detto che a rigore per il
manca la chiave in campo le due non
metterà il tuo preferito
il mio preferito però al camela e detto
io ho preferito stiamo iniziando tali
costumi vestiti con appena arrivato il
corriere ma ma che è una cosa figlia di
fama che è un castello preso il braga ma
è normale pazzo del capo sinora mi
faranno sempre bene e non come voi che
dovete stipendiati per mostrare il
nostro pacchetto c'è la lettiera ho
preso anche una fontana se è utile
arriva mi raccomando non intendo fare
k dentro in quel pacco ci stava solo
questa fontana degli animali perché la
volevi tutta fontana ho chiesto se c'era
un frontale per animali con una tua
stato non ha detto di no qua è felice
della fiori per te e per i tempi ma
quanto è bello così devo dire fanno da
bene questo per un saluto di addio
doveva non mi perde di vista un secondo
te lo vedi fatto ma guarda guarda lui ed
a 160 gradi con gusto e pronta vorrei
portarti con me a fare il puntale del
che cosa ne pensi ritrovo così
confortini la posizione così c'è sempre
meglio dicendo di non sapere
l'associazione mazzino bando mira
dentico esemplare di raffinati
rappezzati gialli per due settimane me
diventati con simpson che è successo qui
e guido quasi pagato una pallina e
dobbiamo far lantero dai no ragazzi sto
andando a fare il puntale non accade
nulla
il volto tipo mamma mia che bregolato è
uno per uno che questi sono tutti pezzi
l'ombrellone non si chiama così la v
guarda che bel albero e si muove dalla
pero non farò l'albero non farò il
presidente non voglio far gara così fino
a keane c'era più lungo una briccola
paurosa ragazzi è gigantesco ma che
pensi desta qua a maganza estorto hanno
manco tocca a kohat scusa era divisa
quel tratto e ora ad alzarlo roma non è
l'albero asi montinaro messa contrario
le cappelle e questo è quello che gli
serva cooper far portale puntate di
oporto
c'è una stranezza è che pende pende
verso della prova fa camminare scusa
viene un attimo capitanata stiamo
mettendo al contrario perché va a
scontrare lo sport non sempre più bassa
vi presento il magico trio per natale
elmo che all'albero vale che a un albero
marco che è un albero lavorare al
puntale e mi manca un'idea interna turno
per avrebbero fatto insieme mi ha
mandato tutte le stelline quindi noi ci
siamo procurati nell'enorme baratteremo
un enorme puntale di un barattolo che
persa la linee di nutella su tutto
l'albero
ora dovete immaginare fingete che già mi
sia l'albero ecco pare tale da non molto
più su deve andare
vale più su del mare
60 valle dare grazie vale abbiamo già
capito che non aiuterà allora crediamo
che la casa sia in presidente facciamo
un test dare di là giusto senza dubbio
cestola io no qui invece proprio la più
bella ma vado un attimo al bagno miei
capelli ci scambiamo più o meno cm dire
fare tutta sta preambolo la stessa ma
una pendenza
ora te ne vai più avanti sapete che non
siamo in tutto dei piedi che cacciari in
iraq a pedali testo numero telefono
troviamo un attimo nella ricerca
ritornare su questo uniamo il barattolo
è incerto ma in modo per bloccarlo la
casa famiglia per fare quest'anno qui
[Risate]
delle palle eva le sai mamma mia che due
non so chi ce l'abbia in festa se sei in
grado di stare così le ore voglio dire
chiamiamo giammarco temo il test finale
chiamino gianmarco marco macchi
differenza riserbo ci serve ci serve una
mano per l'altro dire il pentolone ben
attiva al bagno ma va più piano più pian
pian piano biasi sì sì sì sì sì sì via
in atti mondiale equa per forza della
pianta
ok in sé tante nelle fatiche ma metti
venite per le tasse cosa seria
ok in piano ma come prima come prima
mancano ambito sulla vittima
non ti preoccupare cosa scientifica
questo sia pipino e vitellini che piace
sempre come che fa come andare in
discesa senti la discesa
ti devo dire che l'ha sempre tutto me
fai fare alla fine la carta stagnola
vuole sa mettere la palla a caldo si
sente si stanno dei panni li pensa a
piegarli step successivo prendere le
palline fare una piramide con colla a
caldo e guarda quanto sono bravi giuro
non è minimamente rimasta seduta per
terra e nere solamente al giorno mentre
coi piedi il pianto lì fino alla serie
di una grande va beh se torniamo ma
faccio vedere come stai facendo non
incamerare farsa ferito i segreti da
tanti bravi compenso quando le nostre
tombe
dobbiamo sbrigarci che ci stanno
aspettando in a ma che poi comunque
questo dream team scusa di mazzone marco
dire cazzate
pipino che ti dice che quindi dovrebbero
essere noti gb al bar per toccare la
maglietta di un pirata il brandy metri
perché vigilino e morto so che tu non
avresti proprio saputo da dove caricare
avviene valentina perfumo limone e
battere qualsiasi cosa andiamo dagli
altri dai testa è scientificamente
provato e isole garanzia per andare a
sud in corner
in pendenza questo abbiamo fatto dall
esperimento scientifico barbalbero non
hai capito io non vi sto in fila indiana
ha affittato una casa in pendenza
tendenza sotto sopra e sotto
mi riguarda non posso neanche parlare di
trento che subito volontà comunque noi
avremmo vinto il puntale vedo che anche
pool di sette lavoro ma siete pronti
ragazzi alla meraviglia anticipato
l'idea è impossibile da realizzare e
invece ho fatto io voglio prima vedere o
la cavo enrico vabbè dai ragazzi brava
disfatta allora bisogna fare ma si
schiodi le chiappe e ci viene da una
mano che mi vorrà fare tutto da solo
viene visto fare alberi di natale o per
esempio quando un cretinetto ancora non
si atteggia vi ho detto
stiamo parlando di culla picking ragazzi
si è fatto un bis di quelli crosio
eminem mi sembravi altro invece del
puntare perché il puntale hai usato per
altro si capirebbe tutto peraltro
accetto la sconfitta del puntale del
resto sarebbe la prima volta che non
ebbero riceve qualcosa qui ecco li vedi
quello che ho detto cosa sto giocando
tanto ricorda che non è affatto al
gruppo di recupero per poveri scemi per
i mari fermo e dargli ragione quella con
elicotteri cose scoreggia ma stavolta in
via del volo ai suoi danni larsen
ostaggio mi arrendo verranno qua dentro
c'è un gatto e sotto l'albero ma prima
era fallito tipo antò fa natalizio è un
albero in albero vero che la sua vera
madre 20 è già andato via caprarie pieno
di graffi
vorrei per mancate ternal mente questo
qui lo sanno almeno ambra audio sembra
non credo phone e andrea luca domani a
come mal d'amianto bene che questi solo
nell'ultimo mese ho tanti difetti
ovviamente non è vero e sempre ti chiama
ma io non c'entro niente
è successo sono sconvolta leggo anche
tratta e guglielmo la vostra faida
continua no non avrei quadrare guglielmo
perché in realtà quasi al mondo ma
apportando dalla notte e dopo grandi
sforzi questo è il nostro risultato ma
quando e le ragazze che tingeranno
stupro ma è bello ma il regalo studiata
tutta la notte
ragazzi se vogliamo darvi di questo
video è piaciuto questo sentiti al
canale prima della cappella telematica
grazie per tutte le cose che ci state
scrivendo in questi giorni siete
carinissimi ma grazie anche al nostro
montatore alessandro scrivetegli un bel
messaggio di incoraggiamento perché è
anche grazie a lui se quest'anno abbiamo
il tempo di vari blog mas andare su
twitter e 19 insomma male ti vogliamo
bene noi ci vediamo domani come sempre
alle 14 con un nuovo video
ciao